no
[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 en colombia desde
1958 hasta el 2021 se ha registrado la
desaparición de casi 100.000 personas
según investigaciones de la unidad de
búsqueda de personas dadas por
desaparecidas entre ellas martaguisela
guerrillera del m-19 muerta en una
emboscada en el
1981 su sobrina yisela restrepo ha hecho
un documental sobre el proceso de
búsqueda de sus restos muchísimas
gracias gisela por estar con nosotros
buenos días gracias
usted es artista visual y realizadora
nació en francia donde sus padres
colombianos se habían instalado como
refugiados políticos en 1982 creció en
francia pero actualmente vive en canadá
y su último documental que es el primer
largometraje que ha hecho se llama bajo
el silencio y la tierra y es la historia
de su tía un festival que ha estado en
varios
un documental que estaba en varios
festivales de europa y también de
américa en un momento dado usted se
pregunta en ese documental cómo recordar
a alguien que nunca conociste porque
sintió la necesidad de ir en busca de la
historia de su tía gisela martaguisela
y esa búsqueda llega después de un
proceso de muchos años que yo empecé
cuando me fui justamente para canadá y
fue de conocer la historia de mis padres
que fueron también militantes del m-19
que llegaron exiliados a francia y
buscando investigando y sus archivos en
su historia pues la historia de mi tía
de mi tía emitió camilo pues resonaban
mucho y yo crecí con esa foto de mi tía
ese retrato que mucha gente muchos
familiares crecen con ellas y esa
pregunta de dónde está mi tía empezó a
llegar más y más y más con los años
también me acerque mucho a la realidad
de la desaparición forzada
acercándome a otras familias a otros
amigos que colombianos colombianos
también sus padres habían sido
desaparecidos conocí
defensores de derechos humanos que
acompañaban y que acompañan a las
familias que han hecho una labor
grandísima y todo eso me fue como esa
acumulación que yo dije quiero conocer a
esa mujer quiero desenterrar su
existencia porque la desaparición
forzada es eso es borrar la existencia
de una persona si le parece vamos con un
extracto del documental bajo el silencio
y la tierra
tú me contás un día que tenía sueños con
la tía hice
sobre todo uno tiene
en pesadilla
ya estaba como en túnel de aceituna como
en tierra
yo no la podía salvar
[Música]
bueno aquí estábamos su voz y la voz de
su madre el usaid aunque dice habla de
esa pesadilla que tiene de forma
recurrente que no puede no puede ayudar
a su cuñada que era además su amiga y
usted cuenta
como cuando cumple 19 años le pasa algo
muy importante que es como una semilla
que se planta y es una carta que le
escribe su padre cuéntenos si
cuando yo me iba para canadá
tenía un libro donde mucha gente me
escribía porque yo me iba y no sabía
cuándo iba a volver y mi padre me
escribió aquí hay una una carta
contándome un poco de su perspectiva de
lo que había hecho su militancia y
también al final de esa carta me dice
que tengo que llevar el nombre de mi tía
con orgullo porque yo me llamo gisela en
homenaje a mi tía y esa carta fue como
un detonador para mí y eso fue lo que me
acercó más a la necesidad no solamente
buscarla pero también de saber de dónde
venía yo de cuáles sueños de por la
historia de cuáles luchas y
fue
lo que partió realmente todas esas
preguntas
en ese entonces tenía 19 años los mismos
que su tía martaguisela cuando fue
abatida por el ejército colombiano junto
a otros nueve guerrilleros en 1981 en la
selva del chocó sus restos fueron
sepultados no sabemos muy bien dónde fue
allí en esa selva del chocó
en una fosa común esto lo saben por los
vecinos de la zona y por un guerrillero
también que estuvo con con su tía
cristóbal con el que esa entrevista que
le aporta ese testimonio le acerca más a
su tía con perder quien era claro es
testimonio de cristóbal y el testimonio
de mucha otra gente
me permitió hacer de encontrarme de una
cierta forma con mi tía porque pude
conocerla a través de la voz de otros a
través de la historia de otros y yo creo
que era también muy importante para mí
ese proceso de memoria porque cuando uno
busca a esa persona uno rescata la vida
a través de la memoria de los otros
y me pensé pues me hizo conocer la
militante que ella era
los acuerdos de paz con la guerrilla de
las farc en 2016 abre una especie de
puerta para poder buscar a los
desaparecidos con un marco no
legal y desde entonces han encontrado
9000 cuerpos pero no es posible para
todos cuál es el principal impedimento
para encontrar los restos de su tía yo
creo que bueno depende de los casos en
nuestro caso fue una muerte en combate
por las fuerzas armadas y lo más difícil
hasta ahora ha sido realmente de obtener
informaciones de las fuerzas armadas
han solicitado y no les han dado nada
hemos solicitado y hemos utilizado todas
las medidas posibles desde la fiscalía
hasta yo personalmente
escribirles a las brigadas pero nunca
hemos podido obtener ninguna información
se supone que hay un registro de esas
fosas comunes o cuando mataban a
guerrilleros los entraban y no se
anotaba ningún lado debe haber un
registro de haber
escritos de los combates de haber
información y lo que nosotros estamos
pidiendo ahora es poder acceder a esa
información se supone que estaría
enterrada en el chocó entre piedra honda
y san marino
ustedes consiguen ir a esta piedra honda
porque
según algunos testimonios puede estar
enterrada ahí en una fosa común y tras
muchos días de excavación no se
encuentra nada que siente en ese momento
pues
yo creo que sentí mucha confusión en ese
momento tenía muchas más preguntas
de las que venía yo tenía una pregunta
al principio era donde estaba y en ese
momento muchas otras llegaron si ella no
está aquí entonces donde qué pasó con
ella
pero
rápidamente también es ese sentimiento
digamos de dolor y frustración porque es
mucho silencio
se
cambia porque había también
también mucha solidaridad de la
comunidad y cosas muy bonitas en ese
proceso entonces es una mezcla realmente
de sentimientos son sentimientos
encontrados tienen alguna pista de dónde
puede estar si no está allí en piedra
honda no de momento no en hay un momento
muy emotivo en él hay muchos momentos
emotivos en el documental pero hay uno
especialmente
que es cuando aparece la abuela la mamá
de su padre y de sus tíos y cellay
camilo que también fue asesinado
y según lo que cuenta su abuela como lo
cuenta parece que ella no estaba muy
conforme con la elección de sus hijos no
entendía muy bien cómo había antepuesto
un compromiso político a la vida de
familia y porque finalmente le habían
hecho daño usted te entiende la postura
de su abuela o en ese momento también es
un poco de confusión porque el abuela no
entiende esto al principio fue fue
confusión
y no entendía muy bien de hecho por eso
quise entender por qué para mí ha sido
también muy importante entender a la
familia entender otras posiciones como
la de mi abuela y ella me ha inspirado
mucha fuerza porque yo siempre me he
preguntado realmente ya cómo hizo para
sobrevivir la desaparición fuerza de su
hija el asesinato de su hija y el exilio
de otro de sus hijos y eso es lo que yo
veía en ella mucha resistencia
resiliencia y un dolor de madre muy
profundo porque le negaron eso le
negaron enterrar a su hija dignamente le
negaron un sitio donde ella pudiera ir
ella es consciente que va a ser muy
difícil encontrarla cuando su padre
usted le plantean oiga abuela estamos en
ese proceso de encontrar a la tía y ella
es consciente y les dice esto va a ser
muy complicado es como la
de la experiencia casi no son tan sabias
no entender la historia de marta gisela
de su tía era necesaria para entender
quién es usted lo hemos comentado de
dónde viene lo importante para exiliados
hijos de exiliados políticos y esto lo
vemos también en otro documental que ha
hecho una compañera de radio francia
internacional
angélica pérez que se llama la caja de
pandora en la que usted es la
protagonista y explica no
bueno mis raíces cuáles son quién es
quién soy yo
y en ese proceso es muy muy importante
abrir esa caja de recuerdos esa caja de
pandora y decir bueno de dónde vengo no
claro y es una caja de pandora porque
uno abre
cosas que a veces uno dice por qué por
qué abre esa caja son otra vez muchos
sentimientos
entender la historia de un conflicto es
a la vez
entrar en cómo entrar en la intimidad de
todo un pueblo de entrar en la violencia
también y
pero es necesario y para mí siempre lo
ha sido porque no me podía quedar con
esas preguntas de quién era yo de quién
era mi tía de quién era mi tío y era más
estaba dispuesta a abrir esa caja de
piedra fría y a sufrir a veces por el
dolor también de los otros finalmente
pero nuestra generación
como el legado que tenemos es también
desenredar ese conflicto como aportar
desde nuestra historia a ese camino que
estamos construyendo que estamos
tratando de construir hoy en colombia y
en todos los países me gustaría terminar
con una frase del documental su padre el
momento
cuando están buscando a su hermana dice
querer ir al fondo de las cosas tiene su
impacto no muchísimas gracias y se la
reservó por haber estado con nosotros le
deseamos muchísimo éxito con este
documental bajo el silencio y la tierra
y también que puedan encontrar algún día
el resto de su tía los restos de estiba
muchísimas gracias gracias ayuda y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también por internet en rf
y mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
escala en parís
[Música]